dans le village de 700 habitants toute
la journée une atmosphère particulière
mélange d'émotion et d'effervescence
médiatique
les habitants se souviennent d'un homme
discret et contrairement aux idées
reçues
accessible sur place on retrouve samuel
colin avec paul boyer l'étoile se cache
dans 650 hectares de domaine en
contrebas d'un vallon à l'extérieur du
château familial ce matin les
journalistes font les cent pas
interdiction d'approcher bien entendu
c'est loin des regards que l'ancien
président passe ses derniers moments une
habitude pour lui ici présents
régulièrement à hotton ces dernières
années les habitants se souviennent d'un
homme discret c'était quelqu'un de
simple et d'amicales de toute façon pour
les ans les autos n'est c'est quelqu'un
de discret que je voyais parfois avec sa
femme en voiture
la grand mère de fabrice et ménagères
pour la famille de longues années le
président fait alors des apparitions
remarquées auprès des jeunes du village
et une fois mon frangin s'était décidée
déguisé en bronze et son nom presque
aguichante on va dire et monsieur
giscard d'estaing s'est arrêté avec sa
voiture histoire de nous faire rigoler
quoi est il avait parlé à mon frère
c'était mais très gentiment quoi et puis
ça l'avait fait sourire le château de
l'étoile propriété de la famille de son
épouse restent toutefois pendant
longtemps une résidence secondaire
on le voyait très très rarement les
seules fois où moi j'ai on n'a plus vu
la famille valéry giscard d'estaing
c'était le dimanche quand on allait à
l'église depuis 2010 est le couple est
inscrit sur les listes municipales
valéry giscard d'estaing semble alors
vouloir finir ses jours dans ce village
de 721 habitants c'est ici qu'il s'est
marié
ici aussi que repose sa fille depuis
2018 dans un terrain spécialement acheté
près du cimetière
il devrait la rejoindre après
autorisation spéciale du préfet